are you excited for an upgraded more
powerful console well then it seems like
project Scorpio is your best bet when it
releases later this year I'm Matt and
this is your gamespot news update
complete with six teraflops of power
Gamasutra recently shared images of the
project Scorpio dev kit and it looks a
lot like an Xbox one s in one image you
can see a bunch of older dev kits for
previous xbox consoles with the Scorpio
at the front of the pack however it's
important to note that this isn't final
hardware so it shouldn't be taken as any
indication of what the console might end
up looking like of course we'll keep you
updated when the official consoles
revealed so make sure to LIKE and
subscribe to stay up to date on all of
the project Scorpio news project
Scorpios hardware specs were recently
revealed by digital foundry who were
shown a foursome motorsport demo running
at 60 frames per second in native 4k
however the graphic settings were
equivalent to what we've seen on the
Xbox one and it's important to remember
that other games are likely to vary in
frame rate and resolution stay tuned to
gamespot for more on what project
Scorpio is capable of but in the
meantime check out our video on the six
things you need to know about the
upgraded Xbox
[Music]